and colombia in the population
of milan of
post-conflict Colombian sports
power with the land of trust and I
ask the farc and we ask for the maintenance of
their commitment to peace the
maintenance of the ceasefire the
delivery of weapons and explosives and to
facilitate the tasks  of demining peace
has not failed in Colombia in Colombia it
has succeeded or not but certainly not in it
there is also a will for peace
and
next
there is a strategy against
drug trafficking and demining and new
ways for the political participation of
those who have decided to change the  arms
for peace and the word bases for a
new colombia that is socially fairer and
politically freer and more democratic
today more than ever we must continue to
support peace in colombia and ask
president santos to maintain the
bilateral ceasefire permanently
colleagues i want to start by showing you  a
survey that there was a newspaper in
colombia on monday that the boys and
girls of colombia had voted  do yes